the freedom convoy of truckers
continuing to press their point on
vaccine mandates the mayor of ottawa
asking the canadian government for an
additional 1800 police officers to deal
with the protests the demonstrations
creating a traffic jam in the u.s even
after truckers temporarily shut down a
bridge that connects detroit with canada
and canadian prime minister justin
trudeau is ramping up his criticisms
even comparing them to nazis nice people
of ottawa don't deserve to be harassed
in their own neighborhoods
they don't deserve to be confronted with
the inherent violence of a swastika
flying on a street corner
or confederate flag
or the insults
and jeers
just because they're wearing a mask
and some media outlets using terms like
sedition and threat to democracy to
describe the protest
just think of the language i know it
sounds familiar to you right a threat to
democracy an insurrection sedition we've
heard it called a nationwide
insurrection the movement is being
called an insurrection by some
paralyzing the canadian capital those
with the so-called freedom convoy say
they're staying put it's
a
cult
yes it is
it's not a so-called freedom convoy it
is called the freedom convoy greg ah yes
they're so stupid the media angle please
um
this this is a class issue going on
right now uh you they they just don't
like the working class uh you know uh
what's his face the bozo who's there
trudeau just an elite cupcake
but what you're seeing right now
is
bad appling
that's what they do is they try to find
the worst example of your group and
generalize it to the whole and then when
they can't find one
they make it up for example uh one of
trudeau's uh i don't know staffer's
henchmen whatever you call it uh took a
picture of an anti-semitic flyer saying
oh look what we found look what we found
amongst the truckers that was a
two-year-old flyer that actually
appeared in miami like uh for something
completely different so they couldn't
even bad apple correctly because they
they they're so
irrational remember a lot of these
people when a billion dollars was in
damage was done in the united states uh
um because of the riots there were a lot
of critics some of them in canada and a
lot of them in america saying no no no
no mostly peaceful mostly peaceful when
the looting got out of hand they were
saying well it's kind of a social
injustice that's why people loot these
are the same bozos that suddenly
embraced law and order on january 6th
and are now calling canadian truckers
terrible law breakers and
seditionites i invented that word
seditiousness but okay but but see this
is why we're different we're consistent
we love a good protest against injustice
as long as you cause no damage uh you
don't make the locals lives worse you
don't give your opponents something to
smear you with and i think that's really
important i think that on this side of
the of the of of the protest world these
guys don't protest you know jesse we've
been covering this in the last few days
but they these truckers the commerce
they were planning this for i think at
least two months because you started
seeing it so justin trudeau had he read
dale carnegie's book how to win friends
and influence people
he could have gone
to see them early on and nipped it in
the bud instead now he's calling them
nazis you mean the elite cupcake
delicious
i just i'm so impressed that canada is
making news i've been in this business
for 20 years
i think we had the mayor who smoked
crack in toronto yeah i haven't heard of
peep from canada since the crack smoking
mayor so bravo canada um and we should
send these truckers down if they can
shut the northern border send them to
texas i don't like how trudeau is
stealing
democrat talking points those are
american talking points the race card
okay those were made in america we
should slap a tariff on the race card if
he's just gonna go pluck them up from
america he can't do that and not pay a
price you made a point the other day
dana the confederate flag that doesn't
make sense that there's a confederate
flag in canada that's like
the japanese celebrating thanksgiving it
makes no sense for it to be celebrated
there i don't know i just don't like
also how they're smearing these triggers
just in like mainstream articles they're
saying the angry truckers the angry
truckers the anger blm was like oh these
heartbroken passionate social justice
and have you seen the truckers they're
they're you know what's luke
and they're very calm and they're very
purposeful
justin trudeau gave additional comments
today they would like me to play these
and then i'll get your take on it there
you go
we're all frustrated we're all sick and
tired of restrictions of of mandates i
can understand frustrations with
mandates but mandates
are the way to avoid further
restrictions he's full of it
harold
was going longer
[Laughter]
they say that a lot about him look
i don't
i don't fully understand this story
but what i what i do what i do
understand is that the the truckers are
engaged in civil civil disobedience
it doesn't seem to be moving the
leadership of the country
uh in our country when you disagree with
what politicians are doing you can
certainly protest and stand up but the
two or three ways you try to get the law
repealed is you go to court
you encourage or impress upon lawmakers
through a petition or you unelect those
lawmakers we saw a lot of that happen in
virginia uh with glenn younkin's
election and parents showing that they
want to be involved
in the decision making at schools
so i hear this and i know that attorneys
generals in our country are are making a
point about some of this and they should
about the gofundme page that if it was a
big tech company redirecting people's
money that want to give to any
organization to organization that that
an organization organization that the
tech company wanted to give that's
illegal and the judge i thought handled
that very well yesterday but this
strategy the truckers are using it
doesn't seem to be working if i were
them i would you know go to ottawa to
parliament or
litigate it in court and try to get this
thing overturned if the majority of
people agree with them it'll get
overturned but the it's not just
truckers right so it's truckers but then
it's all these other people across the
country of canada and in america who
have said we agree with you because that
the government is just so over overly
heavy-handed and it's not just
mass mandates and the vaccines but that
is really if they could get to a deal on
that
maybe the truckers would go home look
everybody's fed up i don't care if
you're in canada australia the united
states or podunk iowa it doesn't matter
that's in the united states
yeah everyone's fed up and you know i
looked at this and i said to myself
janine if you're sitting on the bench
and they came before you
uh
and said you know we want an injunction
we want them to stop blowing their horns
or doing what they're doing the the
judge in me says absolutely these people
shouldn't be interfering with the
livelihood of those people in ottawa or
in the area however that didn't apply to
the seditionists and the insurrectionist
that last summer when they were
constantly trying to blow up the federal
courthouse or created the chairs or
spend a billion dollars in damages to
businesses that's another issue but but
to me
i support these truckers this is about
people saying we're going to join
together
we're fed up with you and your nonsense
and your make-believe this and that and
everything changes and i'm vaccinated
for all of you are going to send me hate
mail i'm vaccinated okay but enough is
enough we're damaging children and there
you had him he's had a mask on
earlier he didn't have a mask on and the
same with uh you know stacey abrams it's
enough stop end it and
they haven't
they just got rid of their conservative
leader in canada they need better
leadership there on that side but justin
trudeau absolutely could have nipped
this in the bud early on but he decided
not to and now he's dealing with it like
this hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else